learn learn to learn learning learn
learn learn learn
when I started the business the Martha
Stewart Living Omnimedia our two words
were inspire and inform so you create
the beautiful picture you create the
lifestyle that you think everybody would
aspire to and then you have to tell the
tale again so that's the teaching part
and may that inspire that inspiration
you have to know what you can't fake it
so I learn every single day one of my
mottos is learn something new every day
and I do so it's it's all about
informing yourself so that you can be a
good teacher when you're thinking about
a product launch first thing I would ask
is is it the right time to do product
launch so if your product isn't figured
out if you can't fold the orders now is
not the right time to be on TechCrunch
in my opinion or in any other major
media outlet once you're in a major
media outlet they're not going to cover
you again for some period of time or
ever if you're in the business section
the New York Times they're not going to
cover you four weeks later when your
product is better and you're ready so
make sure that you pick your timing few
things
so there's paid exposure and unpaid
exposure I like to focus on unpaid
because it makes you it forces you to
make better decisions in the beginning
so I would read as I always say the 22
immutable laws of marketing 1,000 true
fans written by Kevin Kelly I would also
read best-selling book PR and publicity
I think it is by Rick Frischmann Fri SH
ma n all the techniques apply to more
than books and learn to tell the story
what are you focusing on are you using
yourself to tell the story and then the
product is associated is it a trend
piece are you trying to tie what you're
doing into a greater trend which is very
effective way of getting media in which
case you're going to get other examples
you need to get comfortable bringing in
sort of cooperative competitors to
create that trend base learn the art of
the pitch and of messaging only once you
have figured that out what I say then
you go out you pay to acquire people
because now if your messaging is off if
costing you money one of the things that
companies do or startups do they come up
with an idea
they'll Google it and if they don't see
it in the first two pages they think its
original you've got to go back right
because over the past 15 years there's
so many different businesses that have
tried and failed you have to go back and
find those and learn from those so
you've got to understand all the
implications and you have to learn from
history and so the best advice I can
give you on a video before talking to
you or emailing with you is that you've
got to find out the history of people
who have tried your idea because there's
a 99.99999% chance that your idea has
been tried before that's not a good
reason not to start it because you might
be able to outperform them but you
better learn from the history of your
idea um because you know what they say
about people who don't learn from
history but the other great secret is
that we're good at lifelong learning
Warren is so much better in some ways in
his 70s and 80s and he was younger that
it's almost awesome wait if you keep
learning all the time you have a huge
advantage and we both just like it and
we have a wonderful group of friends
really wonderful from whom we can learn
a lot yeah so pervasively we were
talking about culture it is when people
disagree and you you can take thoughtful
people disagree you have then the
potential of learning a lot if people
who were disagreeing can say why do we
disagree and work through that
conversation in an intelligent way to
try to find out what's true you can
learn you can make progress it could be
a fabulous thing you have to focus on
always learning you know it's even your
your it's cliche but the reality of it
is is if you take action and try and
fail you're going to learn a lot by the
time you you try it again and
and you will build a foundation of
experience that's going to be ultimately
the rock that allows you to find success
or follow your dreams
I learned something different from
everybody you know it's just like it all
depends on like from yeah just learn you
know always follow your heart always be
real straight up don't take no you know
what I'm saying
common just communist somebody who like
no matter what coming has going on with
one thing you always have something else
going on like he'll always be like if
he's not acting right then he's making
music if he's not making music he's
always finding some ways to brand
himself away from music too and I
respect that you know and I'm saying
he's more than just a rapper Aries are
he's he's like a all-around businessman
and I respect that about coming you know
those little things you learn from guys
like that that you hang around and you
take you take little tips and a platter
so alright one definition that I have
for a good team is a group of people
that makes better decisions as a whole
than would individually make is a sum of
the parts and when you're I think most
smart people like learning right and I
mean that's like one of the thrills of
starting a company right is you're just
that the learning curve can be so steep
and if you can set up a team dynamic
where you're constantly learning from
the people around you then I mean what's
better right these are the people I wake
up every morning and I want to I want to
go learn from and was from is that one
of your heuristics for hiring people to
to like hire people that you learn from
yeah uh and when building a team you
want it to you want to think about the
dynamic so that way you can maintain
this property that the team makes better
decisions as a group than any individual
would when we come into the world we
come in as an empty vessel you don't
know anything you've got no information
and here you are this empty vessel it's
empty glass and all of a sudden you come
into the world and the second you get
into the world you get filled up with
information from who everyone and
everything all around you so pretty soon
you are a factor a result of this
information and so why do you think the
way you think
what does anybody think really thing
because of the information that is
stored in the file
of your mind your mind is nothing more
than a big old foul cabbage it stores
information and so literally the only
thing you can think is what's in the
files of your mind and the only things
in the files of your - what you lurked
what you were told the information
that's in there you cannot pull out a
file of a file cabinet that's not there
and that's the difference between
successful people and unsuccessful
people successful people have file in
their file cabinet that are files that
lead to success when Donald Trump makes
a decision normally that decision
results in success so why is it that his
decisions result in success he has
trials in his mind that are success
based on well fixed file norm it's
normal it's natural brand it's natural
for most rich people because they have
filed in their file cabinet called their
mind net result in actions that result
in success
most people are the opposite why because
most people learn about money about
success about happiness from people who
aren't successful well being happy so if
that's what you learn what do you expect
so what you do well you need to
reprogram need to relearn you need to
put some new information in the files of
your mind and then you need to have some
new actions from those files and you
will get new results now language is
part of communication but there's a much
bigger piece of communication than
language which is the nonverbal
communication that happens between
people most persuasion most bonding most
connection happens on channels other
than the words right so you've heard the
the old estimates that you know over 90
percent of your communication is your
voice tone in your body language
communication is so important and what's
amazing is most people are just
unconscious they're not paying any
attention to it they're not learning how
to communicate with and connect with
other people better so learn about body
language learn about nonverbal
communication learn about how to connect
with people and build rapport
you